holy crap everybody DC and Warner
Brothers just announced they're making a
new God's movie so I'll explain what's
going on my reaction as well as my
reaction to them hiring Ava Duvernay to
direct the film she's not gonna write it
she's just directing it and the
connection to thor ragnarok because we
just got Ragnarok that's Jack Kirby New
Gods is classic Jack Kirby so I'll
explain some of the fun Easter eggs but
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the DC
videos this is just the beginning for
this I'm guessing it's gonna take him at
least two years maybe three years to do
this film depending on how far along
they already are all that they've said
in the announcement is that they've
hired Ava Duvernay to do a New Gods
movie people are asking her like who are
your favorite characters and she said
big Barda of course because big Barda is
a total badass so it doesn't say
anything about what the tone of the
movie is going to be how they're going
to cross over with the other DC
characters because they did say that it
would be connected to the other DC films
like we're getting ready for Aquaman
later this year so it'll have some
connection probably be the Wonder Woman
and Aquaman mythology's just because
Atlantis is ancient you have Poseidon
the Trident of Poseidon that Aquaman
wields you have all the old gods of
Wonder Woman's world what happens when
an old God dies a new God is born the
gods ruled the earth Zeus but most of
you are probably familiar with the more
recent new gods comics like Darkseid war
that happened a couple years ago great
Geoff Johns story but that was dark side
versus the anti-monitor and it sort of
served as a reboot for Darkseid's
character within the DC Universe right
now if you want to read Darkseid new
God's stories Darkseid is in Wonder
Woman's comic book so if you want to
read that story you have to read Wonder
Woman and he's in the process of trying
to retake apocalypse from Lex Luthor so
this past year so far he's been bigger
and badder than ever but he's been in
exile so he's trying to go take famous
Kira so he can turn the Amazonians and
use them as his personal army to retake
apocalypse probably the biggest
questions that I've been seeing since
they made this announcement a couple
minutes ago like literally a couple
minutes ago they just said hey guess
what we're making it a New Gods film is
is what will it feel like compared to
the other DC
movies because you kind of know what
you're getting when you go to see a
Superman or a Wonder Woman film like
they have their own tones like when you
go see a Batman film you already know
what that's going to feel like okay dark
gritty crime drama
BAM got it but totally they're so
different from the other DC films that I
have a feeling that DC will use this as
an opportunity to do their version of
guardians of the galaxy just super weird
characters that not a lot of people have
heard about so their big task isn't so
much in doing a lot of world-building
more in getting people to care about
these really obscure characters because
most people have heard of Darkseid but
they don't know who a lot of the New
Genesis characters are like whose high
father
what about mr. miracle what about Orion
what about dark sides Furies there's so
many characters they haven't said which
characters are going to be in the film
but if the director is saying big Barda
is her favorite character you can pretty
much assume that she's gonna be in it
meaning that they'll also probably
include mr. miracle or Ryan the really
big characters and obviously if you have
dark side you have to include highfather
to sort of explain the relationship
between those two worlds but before we
get into too much speculation the thor
ragnarok easter eggs are actually pretty
cool most of you may already know Jack
Kirby's original intention for the New
Gods comics so the New Gods is a group
of characters were actually you know
collected their stories in something
called Jack Kirby's fourth world what
happened is is when Jack Kirby was still
at Marvel making those classic Avengers
titles with Stan Lee he came up with
this idea while he was working on tales
of Asgard which was the original Thor
comic like Thor had his own title but
most of his original stories were
published in tales of Asgard so what
happened is as Jack Kirby wanted to
change that universe in a really
fundamental way so he got the idea when
he was plotting out like 90 plus issues
of tales of Asgard that he would use the
concept of Ragnarok to get rid of a lot
of those characters and out of that
would be born the fourth world
characters but Marvel editorial totally
wasn't down with that they're like these
Thor characters are too popular you
can't kill them off so Jack Kirby
finished his original for Ragnarok story
which was sort of the basis for the Thor
Ragnarok movie a lot of people died
people will reborn like Thor was reborn
as this amazing new version of himself
and then he left Marvel because they
didn't want his fourth world story and
did it at DC so the whole basis for the
existence of the new gods characters at
DC Comics is because Marvel didn't want
Jack Kirby to get rid of all the
characters from the Thor comics because
that's where they would originally take
in place my time has come with my crown
is reunited with eternal flame I shall
be restored to my full might I will
tower over the mountains and bury my
sword deep as well let me get this
straight
you're going to put your crown into the
eternal flame and then you suddenly
grows bigger house if you haven't read
those original New Gods stories they're
really just like this mythic tale of
evil versus good is very Shakespearean
in that Darkseid son Orion is raised by
his greatest enemy hi father and then
vice versa so mister miracle hi father
son is raised by Darkseid on apocalypse
in complete oppression but he overcomes
that becomes the world's greatest escape
artist and if you're not reading the mr.
miracle comic book right now it's
probably one of the best new titles like
the artist was actually commenting on
this new God's article like who's your
favorite character so early speculation
because it sounds like DC wants to let
this be super weird and super awesome
that it's gonna be mostly just the new
gods characters with a couple little
small points of crossover in the way
that Wonder Woman was part of the DC
Universe and connected to the other
films but you really only saw that
letter from Batman at the beginning and
at the end but the rest of the movie
like 99% of the movie was just the
Wonder Woman characters but as they make
new announcements I'll just do update
videos and let me know in the comments
what kind of bonus videos do you want me
to do for new gods because even though
we don't know the story you can assume
that there'll be a version of their
origin story that will be told it in the
same way that Marvel sort of changed
Thor Ragnarok from Jack Kirby's original
story I'm expecting a couple edits but
we don't know what it's gonna look like
assume that it's not going to be the
Zack Snyder looking version of the new
God's because we got a little concept
art for Darkseid and obviously there was
the whole Steppenwolf debacle just
assume that they're not doing that so
any of the stuff that was set up during
Justice League is probably going to be
soft retconned
into whatever they want to do with this
new gods movie so I know that raises
some questions about flashpoint and
potential DC universe reboots don't
worry about any of that stuff until they
officially confirm stuff just don't
worry about it just assume that new guys
is gonna be this really weird thing off
by itself with like a couple Wonder
Woman or Superman points of crossover
because Kryptonians galactic race Wonder
Woman old gods there's a lot of
different options when it comes to
connecting the mythology of Fourth World
to the DC Universe but obviously the big
thing at the moment right now in
addition is the Avengers infinity war
trailer that's posting tomorrow so just
everybody freaked out about all the
stuff that DC and Marvel are dropping
right now but I'm really excited that
they decided to do a fourth world movie
I'm more curious as to what it's gonna
look like and what the tones gonna be
but I wouldn't be surprised if they hold
a lot of those types of announcements
for their Comic Con presentation so it
might be a little while before we get
more information but click here for that
teaser for the Avengers trailer and
click here for brand new flash thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight